It's surprising that the two of us were both in a good mood and drinking so much when we entered the
study group.
That's
why Germany and the whole economy were put together, but
I was surprised that the green onion on the paper was
the birth of the cow.
I don't care if you choose a book with that teacher z I didn't know the song
, but if that's the case, wouldn't it be okay if you wrote another one?
I don't mind if I receive it,
but it's fine, but the Prime Minister's book is fresh and I'm fishing for choppy eggplants, but I'm not interested
.
I wonder who these small fish
chefs are?
Yoryoji Peel off the disguise of the award-winning elites and set them up.
Version 4 I won't let the kids do what they want, so I'm
a cook mother who made it to the senbatsu finals of Blow Fang Archi
.
[music]
If you want to practice
[applause]